do you have any insight regarding the
antibody resistant covered mink mutation
in denmark
uh 12 plus people are sick and much of
the country is locked down
yep oh man i know of it is barely as
is about all um point early on there is
thought of
zoonotic um evolution
i guess that's not it's not zoonotic
sonic would just be transmission but
um well maybe it is um but jumping back
and forth and then back again
uh with something else i can't remember
what um but the but
it's it's clearly happening in the minx
um oh i guess it was it's
it's been seen in some cats some house
cats but hasn't been observed to go back
yeah same with dogs same with dogs right
so some domesticates and i guess these
minks
are farmed so these are effectively
domesticated as well otherwise how would
you know
here's the right now thing and i i
should have looked into this i didn't
know the question was going to come up
yeah one of the back in the early days
of covid where we were discussing lab
leak hypothesis that was this year
that was very recently but still the
early days
back in the day we used to discuss the
lab league hypothesis
and the serial passage experiments that
likely took place in the lab in
presumably training the virus
to be a better model for whatever the
study was that was
going on if this was a lab leak that's
the best explanation is that somebody
was
building a virus that would be good for
studying something like how to create
vaccines maybe vaccines that covered
more than one
emergent coronavirus but anyway
one of the questions was and i've now
forgotten exactly
why this question came up but one of the
questions was
could one of these serial passage
experiments have been
in and i think it was mustelids it may
or may not have been minks it may have
been ferrets i don't remember
um but the question
was did somebody
infect a colony of mustelids that is
weasels
and serially passage the virus between
them
because i think it was that mustelids
had
i can't remember was it a spike protein
that was a good model for humans or i
don't know
but uh but in any case if it was the
case
that this is a lab leak and if the lab
in question
serially passaged it through mustelids
then it would be highly likely yeah that
it would
infect mustelids that came into contact
with people like where like a mink farm
yeah and it would not be surprising that
it would then be able to go the other
way because it may already have gone
the other way yeah right and so um
so that's that's two ifs at the
beginning of that um
but uh you know absent that
it's hard to say because this is
actually one part of that
is something that we spent a lot of time
talking about and you spend even more
time than i did
earlier we were talking a lot about
covet the idea that this was an
unintentional lab leak from
research into the virus seems
really very very likely to both of us so
that's a not very big if in our heads
and then the
bigger if just you know in part for me
because i just don't
i don't remember the evidence for or
against is were they doing serial
passage experiments
almost certainly yes if it was lab but
were they doing serial passage
experiments with
mink or with mustelids and if mustelids
then
um expecting this to be able to be
bobbing back and forth between minks and
humans is not
unexpected that's the thing if this was
a lab leak which seems highly likely
then the only really iffy
question in here is d did the serial you
know almost certainly serial passage
experiments would have
been part of this in fact they would
almost have to be in order for the
evidence that this is a lab leak
uh to be accurate yeah right um
but the only weak link in the chain
is where mustel it's involved and
um i certain again this is you know
people say well why do you need to know
we've got the virus now let's fight it
no this is why you need to know exactly
right this is exactly why you need to
know is that
the uh tissue level promiscuity of the
virus
and the ability to jump between species
are things that would surely have been
altered by such experiments so we need
to know what they were there's just
it it's actually the rare thing about
the epidemiology of this virus
that would have no that that would hinge
in no way
on what the origin of the virus was and
that's not to say that we can point to
exactly what the effects would be
or why um but the idea that it doesn't
matter now let's just
let's just fight the thing it's like we
need to know what thing it is that we're
fighting yeah
actually we have to 100.
you